So far it's really pretty much been
the tracking like we saw before.
But now the part of filter tracking,
we've got a model tracking it.
But the thing that we're going to do
now that's a little bit different,
this is sort of the cool part is.
We're not going to assume
that our appearance and
observation model remain constant.
Basically the idea is we're going to,
sort of, update our,
the model as we get
new images coming in.
Now a sort of a standard way of
doing this, and, by the way,
this works really poorly so
don't do it is.
I have a model, appearance, I look
around, I say that's my best one, and
I say, okay,
I guess it's changed a little bit,
let me pull out that model and
I'll find that in the next image.
And, eventually,
what happens is you get drift.
And the model lands on that.
There's this really, really cool thing.
Oh, you can't see.
Okay.
I'm going to pretend like there's this
really great car.
Sitting right over here and
you know, eventually and
it just gets stuck on there.
And the thing that I was tracking
would go, it would go away.
But if I don't update my
model then as things change,
I can't find it so well anymore.
So what we do here instead is
with every new appearance,
we're going to change our eigenbasis.
Right?
This is a,
this is the set of eigen vectors
that let's our It says reconstruct.
We're going to change that a little bit.
And that allows for
a small variation in appearance, but
it still going to try to do things
like track the general class.
And so
the trick is just as it is written here.
Given the basis set, B of t minus one,
that we use to find the loc,
the observation at time t minus one.
We, that allows us to compute
a new eigenbasis, B of t,
that we're going to use now
to evaluate our measurements.
All right?
So the idea is we're updating
this eigenbasis, but it's adding sort
of it's a small variation each time, so
we can't radically change
what things look like.
We can change them a little bit.
And this referred to as
an incremental subspace update.
As you remember from PCA we said
the whole reason that we're doing this
dimensionality reduction is
the idea that we believe our images
lie in some subspace.
But we have to find that subspace
within the bigger feature space.
So that's why this is referred to
as an Incremental Subspace Update.
And why are we doing this?
Basically, we are accounting for
appearance change.
So we might be tracking the,
the object in the image.
It's translating, it's rotating,
it's maybe shearing, but
if I rotate out of the plane,
as far as the camera is concerned,
my face is changing its appearance.
As I go sideways,
it usually goes worse, but that's okay.
The idea is that I want to
model that change.
So we're learning a new
appearance representation as,
as the image area changes.
In the papers that I've
been telling you about,
they base it upon, on this recursive
SVD algorithm, which is kind of nice.
So you don't have to do the whole
eigendecomposition, decomposition again.
So you can do this quickly in real time.
That part doesn't matter so much.
Essentially what you have is
an algorithm, that allows you,
it's kind of like a running
mean algorithm, where you're
using the most recent examples more
strongly than the older examples.